first pitch tonight 8:00 Eastern Time
alongside Dan Schulman and Jessica
Mendoza and Buster only it will be Aaron
Boone back here in the Rich Eisen show
how are you Aaron I'm good how you doing
rich I'm fired up I'll be honest with
you yeah you know being a lifelong
Yankee fan I didn't see this one coming
I did not think there would be a playoff
game this year and and I'm genuinely
excited what do you think about the
tonight's game yeah I'm excited too and
and and I think from a Yankee standpoint
you know they feel like that that kind
of scary team that that I think
Cleveland sitting there watching
probably if he had truth serum pulling
for pulling for the twins you know I
think the Yankees maybe that one team
especially in that first division series
in the best-of-five situation that kind
of scares Cleveland a little bit just
because the bullpens so deep their
offensive capabilities but I'll tell you
what being around the the the workout
yesterday in the press conference
there's a little swagger and a I feel
like a quiet confidence to what the
twins are doing and you know you could
make the case it's been the best offense
in the second half of the season hitting
the ball over the fence a ton and and
giving the ball to a guy that's attic
right here in urban Santana no there's
no doubt about that and and you know the
Yankees and the twins at a three-game
set a couple weeks ago in the Yankees
just absolutely obliterated them and
always have a good a good game against
the twins more often than not over the
last decade and a half that said it's
just a one game playoff tonight and and
they are a team that had 100 losses last
year so they they must be feeling a
little bit destined as well right now no
question about that what what which
matchup do you think fits well for the
twins tonight Aaron well the fact that
they have Santana going you know I'm not
quite sure people realize how good a big
seasons he's had you know over 200
innings 16 wins a lower and run average
I think the one and the one thing if
he's on and he's his slider is on and
it's a pitch he'll throw almost 40
percent of the time it's one of the best
sliders in the game if he's commanding
that and he's got a real chance
18 the swings and misses as much as the
Yankees do however he's also prone to
giving up the long ball and if that
slider is not being commanded that
things up in the zone a little bit you
know that's that's death at Yankee
Stadium especially with with the power
that they have
especially the power they have in the
middle of their lineup so I'm just
really looking forward to that matchup
where is Santana on it does he have that
great command with this slider which
which will be kind of the key to
everything tonight and then what about
the Twins lineup against Severino what
do you think matches that well for
Minnesota there well they come in
collectively swinging the bat really
well and you think about when Miguel
Sano their Slugger went down this team
got better and and they had they they
got power sources from so many different
places in the lineup you know Polanco
Rosario Dozier at the top you know they
they can Beach in so many different ways
and you know
Severino first time pitching in a
playoff game 23 years of age you know if
he's on top of this game he's going to
be very tough to hit because this stuff
is so elite but all of a sudden you add
some elements you know you get a little
bit of a lead mistakes to the Minnesota
Twins more often than not in the second
half have turned into homeruns and in
this ballpark a couple of mistakes on
either side and the long ball maybe the
difference and so so no is not there
though tonight Aaron I mean that's a
significant hole in the lineup just with
that and it sounds correct yeah but
that's what's been remarkable about this
20 they became a better offense when
Sano went down there's so many guys
stepped up we saw Rosario and Polanco
and these guys really emerge in the
second half of the season not just
picking up the slack but hitting for
power and and hitting for power likes
the nose so yeah they miss them because
he is the real deal from from a power
standpoint to know but but they've had
everyone step up and not only pick up
the slack but really fill his shoes
Aaron Boone joining me here as he's
getting set to call the Yankees and
twins Wild Card Game two
ESPN let's talk about tomorrow Rockies
and Diamondbacks it's been I mean that's
been that's been the expected matchup
for weeks if not months how do you see
that playing out in the National League
yeah
toss-up I'm actually going to that game
with my wife we're going as fans we live
in Arizona so we'll be there ice so
you're gonna you have the pool seats you
can be by the pool I will be your will
be right actually right by the Rockies
dugout okay so I'm looking forward to
watching it because those are two really
good teams and it's a great matchup in
with grain key going on the mound and
then I don't know if anyone knows who
John Gray is across the country but he's
an emerging ace I mean this guy I think
is going to go in there and pitch really
well I actually we had to make our picks
I actually picked the the Rockies in
this game because I think John Gray has
a chance to go in there and be a real
difference maker
Diamondbacks a little banged up
Goldschmidt a little banged up down the
stretch
I think the Diamondbacks pose the
biggest threat to the Dodgers in the
second round but this game tomorrow
night should be a great one in its and
it's a really good pitching matchup with
Greinke and gray so the sodium pentathol
on the document' they're rooting for the
Rockies tonight what you're saying you
know what yeah I think so again true
serum I think yeah they're pulling for
the Rockies to get gray out because they
know if they have to play the
Diamondbacks it's Robbie ray in Game one
Robby ray pride in Game five a guy
that's really had the number of the
Dodgers this season and you've obviously
played in a playoff game and pinstripes
and you know what it's like the crucible
is Erin what do you think's going
through Erin judge's mind today what do
you think here man I think he's so good
at this kind of stuff at moments at just
you know he carries himself with such a
was such a calm with such a class like a
veteran and so I think from a the moment
standpoint from the excitement the
nerves all this that that come with
playing in this game especially a
do-or-die win or go home game
I think he'll handle it as well as you
can and I think it'll be a guy that from
a pulse and a heartbeat standpoint I
think
Bok comes down to if he lays off the
pitches that Ervin Santana wants him to
chase then he's got a chance that
success and really have his power make
an impact and I don't know if you saw it
you might be you know prepping for
tonight's game a little bit more
whatever did but Derek Jeter just had
his first press conference as part owner
of the Miami Marlins I did not see that
he's come in guns blazing fire and some
dudes I know that what you think of that
Aaron you know from afar you know a
little interesting that he's you know I
mean in the end of the day it's it's on
it's on him and and you've got to make
the decisions that you think are best
for the organization but it did seem a
little bit quick from afar of a fire and
some guys that maybe you haven't got to
know yet did you think he's got some
Steinbrenner seriously absolutely I
think there are a lot of qualities about
the boss that that Derek Jeter respected
and and I'm sure maybe something that he
takes with them a little bit now I'm
thinking this Aaron cuz we had one of
our our listeners tweeted tweeted at the
show in the last hour when we talked
about Jeter wondering if he would ever
come back for an old-timers day in
Yankee Stadium and my thought is Jeter
is the type to say that that part of his
life is closed that he would not saying
he would never show back up again but as
long as he's the owner of the Miami
Marlins that's his team and I would
prefer to say that that Jeter's turned
the page what would you say to something
like that I would say he definitely
turned the page and I don't expect him
to be at old-timers day very often but I
said dude if there was a day in the next
20 30 years I think there is one that he
will come back for at some point to be a
part of and well it'll be a big deal
what would that day be 20 27 20 27 yep
okay am I missing something right there
what wait no I just oh you just made it
up no I don't know I just seems to me
that it's four for us Yankee fans this
is a
this is wild to see that he's in charge
of a team and Mattingly is his employee
I can't believe that that's kind of
crazy right
it really is I guess you live long
enough Aaron you take care of yourself
have a good game tonight okay
all right thank you rich take care
that's good the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy